yeah actually sorry we're live here now  with prague and it's a really tough day  at work today is it  yeah it is and um  yeah i'm just hoping to play my best in  the third game and we'll see how it goes  and and how is that when you you've been  on such a role and then you play against  magnus today and you're you're facing uh  a next level type opposition  um  yeah  it is uh  yeah of course magnus is very tough to  play and uh  and  yeah i thought i had something in this  game but then i went uh with this rook  before rooker 4 which was just very bad  otherwise i think my play was  pretty okay today  good luck prague and we hope for a fun  comeback yeah thank you